bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 16
novembre la médiathèque du canal a
rouvert ses portes après 18 mois de
travaux
elle accueille à nouveau du public
depuis ce mercredi mardi soir le public
de saint cyr l'école est entré dans les
confidences d'alexis moncorgé le
comédien lauréat d'un molière à partager
la folie amoureuse d'un jeune médecin
allemand et les célébrations de la
grande guerre continue aux
clayes-sous-bois un spectacle rendant
hommage aux combattants venus d'ailleurs
étaient proposées elle rouvre enfin ses
portes après 18 mois de travaux la
médiathèque du canal accueille à nouveau
le public depuis ce mercredi 16 novembre
des aménagements ont été apportés le
musée de la ville est dorénavant intégré
au rez-de-chaussée de l'établissement
nous avons visité les locaux depuis
avant sa réouverture regard des
premières visites guidées de la
médiathèque du canal ce bâtiment
construit sur cinq étages atone en 1993
la médiathèque du canal ouvrait ses
portes à montigny le bretonneux 23 ans
plus tard elle s'apprête à montrer son
nouveau visage
après un an et demi de travaux les 130
mille ouvrages ont réintégré ses rayons
la capacité d'accueil de la médiathèque
est plus petit puisqu'un et agen
un espace au rez de chaussée
est dédié
au musée l'expérience de la médiathèque
du petit canal
nous a montré qu' il y avait un intérêt
à accueillir des publics de différents
âges dans
dans les espaces on a voulu également
des espaces
assez mixte dans dans le fait on vient
pour emprunter mais également ses
journées sur place soit pour travailler
soit pour se détendre grande évasion
bouillon de culture la répartition est
envisagée de manière thématique
les plus petits ont leur propre espace
des espaces réaménagés et un
accompagnement du public par les 33
employés de la structure
on a fait un document mode d'emploi de
la médiathèque pour donner à lire un peu
le bâtiment donc un plan et puis ce
qu'on peut trouver dans chacun des
étages voilà pour avoir déjà un premier
repère donc ça c'est forcément un
document qu'on va distribuer et puis il
y aura également des collègues au moins
jusqu'à fin décembre qui vont être là en
plus des postes traditionnels des
services publics pour justement
accompagner les gens allaient au devant
de répondre à leurs questions on l'a
vraiment les accompagner dans le nouveau
bâtiment en fait elle la médiathèque du
canal accueille près de 17000 personnes
chaque mois ses portes se rouvriront le
mercredi 16 novembre
on prend maintenant la direction de
versailles deux artistes peintres
il y expose jusqu'au 20 novembre farah
nehalem sont parents et artistes
peintres peinture à l'huile
évoquant mer et montagne pour l pastel
pour lui tous les deux originaires
d'iran ils s'inspirent de leurs voyages
et rencontres
écoutez les mois jugé inspiré souffle au
mouvement sur le reflet et du travail
beaucoup coloré la peinture à l'huile à
une certaine souplesse qui permet la
réflexion et qui propose aussi de la
matière si on veut et grâce aux glacis
superposés on peut avoir une profondeur
également il ya beaucoup de qualité dans
la peinture à lui connaissez-vous la
marque ce bruxe ce brusque accès de
folie parfois meurtriers à me kate une
folie malaisienne qui a inspiré stevans
faig l'auteur autrichien on écrira une
nouvelle en 1922 et alexis moncorgé un
comédien français a choisi de l'adapter
sur scène une adaptation qui a déjà
changé sa vie la création de son
s'accompagner de 130 représentations et
un molière
regardez il faut que je vous décrivais
les lieux c'était dans la grande salle
du palais gouvernemental une salle
immense partout d'éclairer presque vide
colonie hollandaise 1912 un jeune
médecin allemand au fin fond de la
jungle il s'ennuie s'enivre il est
repoussé par une femme qui voulait
avorter et devient amok lamock en
malaisie ce sont les fumeurs d'opium qui
sont pris du soudainement d'une crise de
folie meurtrière sûr que lui selon mme
vike qui a écrit la nouvelle ce n'est
pas une crise de folie meurtrière c'est
un homme qui va tout à coup tomber
complètement fou amoureux d'une femme et
qui va tout faire pour la retrouver lui
sauver la vie car elle comprend que cet
avortement pour elle c'est une question
de vie ou de mort
mise en scène minimaliste éclairage
intimiste
alexis moncorgé seul sur scène et
confient les tourments de cet homme une
passion dévorante pour le personnage
comme pour son interprète des mondes et
la lecture l'avait quand j'ai refermé le
bouquin je suis rentré complètement fou
furieux dans l'adaptation
dans la production j'ai tout mener de
front
avec mon équipe artistique j'ai choisi
agité sur chaque étape du travail
la pièce est présentée depuis un an et
demi à paris et en tournée
une reconnaissance du public mais aussi
de la profession en mai dernier alexis
moncorgé recevez le molière de la
révélation masculine comme un animal
anamah à l'occasion de la commémoration
du 11 novembre la ville des
clayes-sous-bois multiplie les
événements culturels
jeudi dernier à l'accueil et la
compagnie strasbourgeoise mémoire ville
cette compagnie crée des spectacles
vivants autour de la mémoire collective
à nos morts s'intéresse aux soldats
venus combattre pour la france regardez
alors toujours dans judas indochinois
sénégalais maliens malgache ils ont
combattu pour la france lors de conflits
armés
la compagne les mémoires vives les 10 à
nos morts à ces soldats des guerres
mondiales et à leur descendance
essentiellement des recherches
historiques on a essayé de compenser ça
en aurait en 1h15 de montrer un maximum
de choses enfin de dire il était là ils
étaient là ils étaient là ils étaient là
par tous a priori on avait appris que
qui avec nous c'est à dire nous les
blancs qu on relativise un peu les
choses quand on apprend qu effectivement
et à tout le continent africain qui se
mobilisent quoi et que la première armée
d'afrique est la véritable armée
française est constitué à 60 70 % de
l'afrique alors africain
demandez au bout par ans une chaire de
village marque une forme créée à la
suite des émeutes de 2005 à nos morts à
10 ans cette année le spectacle a été
labellisé centenaire de la guerre 14-18
par la région alsace et actions
mémorielle de transmission par la
mission du centenaire
on a utilisé notre nos moyens
d'expression aux armes à prendre une
expression de césaire nos armes
miraculeuses donc on est on est des
poètes on n'est pas des historiens on
s'est quand même dit que on raconter
quelque chose qui est historique et
qu'il fallait pas qu'on raconte
n'importe quoi
s'ils ont bien sûr il ya des traits qui
sont grossis bien sûr il ya des choses
qui sont un peu romancée hip hop chant
et théâtre urbain des styles artistiques
résolument contemporain pour traiter une
histoire française qu'il ne faut pas
oublier
c'est assez soudain il va venir dit à
l'autre parce que pendant ce temps m
c'est pas glorieux
on retrouve maintenant notre rendez vous
cinéma hebdomadaire et gaëlle pineau du
grenier à sel de trappes nous donne son
coup de coeur de la semaine ce vendredi
18 novembre à 20h45 vous pourrez
découvrir ou redécouvrir ce western hors
norme qui est little big man little big
man ou le programme dans le cadre de
notre rétrospective de grands films
classiques que nous avons appelé les
lumières du grenier
ce film a été réalisé en 1970 par arthur
penn qui avait déjà fait et bonnie and
clyde auparavant
pour ceux qui n'ont jamais eu la télé
comme moi vous allez avoir l'impression
de voir un nouveau film car le grand
écran nous donne vraiment une vision
d'une fresque grandiose c'est on
découvre vraiment le film alors pour
parler un petit peu plus du film ce
c'est un set un contrat d'apprentissage
de jack crabe et antihéros ballotté
entre deux cultures
il est admirablement interprété par
dustin hoffman et on passe de différents
registres multiples projets sont passe
de la comédie à la tragédie lyrique ou
bien encore du western métaphysique et
dustin hoffman interprète dans
différents types d' aventure un guerrier
indien un roi du revolver il passe aussi
de deux vendeurs ambulants attrapeurs la
séance de vendredi 18 novembre à 20h45
sera précédée au grenier à sel d'une
présentation par thomas bourez qui est
journaliste cinéma à studio ciné live et
la france 24 vous retrouvez bien sûr
toutes ces informations sur cinéma
grenier à sel point com
pour cet agenda plusieurs rendez vous à
noter les deux premiers sets au théâtre
national de saint quentin en yvelines
ce mercredi soir le chef enrique mazzola
dirige l'orchestré national d'île de
france des oeuvres classiques de chopin
ou de barta tch et une pièce
contemporaine celle de john williams
composait pour la liste de schindler le
film de steven spielberg autres soirées
au théâtre national le samedi 19
novembre et c'est de la danse le
chorégraphe olivier dubois et ses dix
neuf danseurs parle de la fragilité
humaine dans son plus simple appareil
regardez cet extrait
et pour ceux qui souhaiteraient aller au
théâtre direction plaisir et l'espace
coluche une pièce suit neuf femmes d'âge
et de condition diverses dans un hammam
à alger
regardez donnent marine une fois une
cigarette pareil ça repose limoges
mettez le dans brel brouille plus tard à
mon âge je me cache encore pour fumer
mais mon mari faisait pas et tout à coup
j'ai vu un homme un vrai je me suis mise
à courir vers lui je bondis fait les
guerres comme une cave elle le soleil ni
mines et 9 ans m'apporter loser deux
insulaires et pour ceux qui sont plus du
genre à frissonner au cinéma la nuit de
l'horreur de montigny le bretonneux est
fait pour vous au programme du vendredi
25 novembre
ce conte jury de american nightmare 3 et
voilà le cetud que la culture est
maintenant terminé merci de nous avoir
suivis les programmes continus sur tv
fil 78 moi je vous dis à la semaine
prochaine
nous